ja
tumore der schock
rsn wort guthiess matches vielleicht hat
dass ihn das königshaus fast täglich
einmal aufs handy anruft ist für stefan
trapped nichts besonderes mehr
doch wie kommt es dass einer mit 35
jahren bereits chef über 320 köche ist
und den könig von thailand zu seinem
kostgänger zellen werfen davon handelt
dieser filme
[Musik]
könig russ deshalb stand für mode
jetzt muss ich das meinen ruf schieber
und jede muss tyler dass sie müssen was
machen und dass das paradies oder morgen
am 8
[Musik]
die gäste des luxushotels oriental
mandarin in bangkok würden sich in den
katakomben und treppenhäusern des
personals leicht verirren
stefan trap kennt jede stufe vor fünf
jahren kam er als nummer zwei des
chefkochs ins hotel
seit zwei jahren ist er selber der chef
und als bündner
das ist für ihn von anfang an klar so
weit weg von zu hause nutzen wir uns
nicht einfach so dass du kannst nicht
alles schön magath direkt oder das buch
zieht also wenn es zukunft oder zehn
künstler und der tod bist du denn dass
was geht ab und zu aber das ist einfach
so jaja lockt auch regula da kann man ja
gar nicht gelang es mit viel würde
kochbücher pauli das wird sich schon auf
twitter wissen lassen dass ich spieler
genau wären hier sind der kauf von
münzen aber das ist jetzt das buch waren
jeden tag bucher und darum geht das aber
missbrauch durch unter umständen
regelmäßig durch das buch auf jeden fall
regelmäßig
nach der lehre im bündnerischen an dem
wechselte er auf anraten seines
fachlehrers in fünf sterne häuser
rosa bad ragaz dubai kalifornien manila
phuket und nun bangkok waren die
stationen
ok keine boni mehr in die defensive
nicht so jupiters pink halben englisch
heißt also je nachdem
wenn ein englisch gedreht die auf
englisch habe viel tun hat nicht
eigentlich rede ich muss ja auch nicht
der bcm lisch hängt und first in brüssel
verständigen
mit seinen 35 jahren ist trap einer der
jüngsten chefköche seiner kategorie
weltweit und damit auch viel jünger als
die meisten köche in seinem team
wir haben jährliche dort sich geben
das ist der polo ist 240 denn alles scho
spitznamen apollo ist der polo wir
denken
obwohl auf dem mond flogen ich hätte er
dauert von blum zeit mit ihm abholen
das sind zuspitzen
sie nennen seine mitarbeiter schlicht
chef stefan und als solcher steht er
täglich selber in der küche aus freude
am beruf aber auch aus der überzeugung
heraus dass er seinen leuten ein vorbild
sein will ein ganz einfacher salat und
ich sage würde dass gunter unter
handwerk ich bin sehr kreativ ob es
jetzt ja bisher saillant schwer zeigen
das müssen wir jetzt mit general manager
sundar stehe ich aber ich will mich
selber bezeichnen auch sehr kreativ was
ich kann mir die grenze
ich denke wenn man das meeting kennen
zum beispiel und wir reden am ehrenmal
wo slow down so quasi oder will mir gott
ein idealer kopf und man kann so machen
und so machen also ich glaube dass zu
stärken von mir so optimal
immer vor toni der und computerausdrucke
1 million hair henker und verteilen denn
das modem ihrer körper selber wissen es
genau was jetzt vorbereiten und wir mal
seinen fittichen
[Applaus]
das leben in bangkok entspreche ihm sehr
er passe in dieses treiben sagt er der
in thusis aufgewachsen ist und einst ein
talentierter skirennfahrer war
sie kaufen auf dem markt café er
ausschließlich für sich privat ein und
auch nur früchte oder gemüse für die
hotelküche gelten höhere hygiene
standards
erste früchte abteile klar wenn man dann
ins fleisch und dann wird man schnell
herum und schweizer doch kein fleisch
verkaufen
wahnsinn wahnsinn aber das kann ich
absolut nicht als kandidat um das wir in
europa ist ja so hygiene vorschrift das
muss alles kühlt sie und weg um auf
thailand riesig froh sind am morgen am 7
der liefert indem man pick up trucks und
die unschuld rahmen wie hat denn häufig
sind sie immer nach dessen und avanti
für mich das faszinierend
im hotel oriental man darin werden nur
fleisch und fisch serviert von denen die
herkunft kontrolliert und garantiert ist
so manche delikatesse bestellt trepca in
europa das ist jetzt alles in port wo
für europa grund der in cortina und
darstellung macher und kontrolliere was
user dass ich alles darum das soll jeder
läuft bis vor zwei jahren als er chef
wurde bot das haus auch umstrittene
produkte wie haifischflossen an
das ist heute nicht mehr der fall nicht
in eine ganze kompanie dass vermieter
würden wir mal ein sehr großes
geschäften mit der chinese mit
haifischflossensuppe zum beispiel oder
unternehmer wirklich mehr so überlegen
dass der monat aber heutzutage sich das
einfach zu heikel blue fin tun also der
blauflossenthun herauf kürzer wäre denn
nur jeder vierte bürger wird einfach
über wichtig
witting
[Musik]
im täglichen meeting mit den küchenchefs
verteilt stefan tripp die menüs okay so
klaus tschütscher verschleiß parma heavy
users leistung maschinen der red land
denn klaus used to zentimeter high can
you come into zentimeter high res
zentimeter weit in fünf zentimetern
sowie nie positiv ist bremst und dienst
friday dienstag 7
wer die wm
[Musik]
jetzt mittlerweile schottland braucht
also als mini ak dass ich der chef bin
williams einfach ja am anfang ein
schlechter witz mallorca zu nitrat
gröner soeben rainer wo mit gerne in
front of der husumer laufenden geschäft
gehört wo für einen geschäfte in
hochmoor dakar träger gar kein jetzt
einfach bescheid kommt man so aber
mittlerweile das geschäft bin und ich
bin ziehen wo es denn zeige ja oder sie
beschäftigen also das ist ja so für
neuen restaurants und zwölf küchen ist
trap verantwortlich jeden tag besucht er
seine köche und hilft mit wenn es ihn
braucht
geschmack hunger also
kochen kann jeder wenn man im september
stellte verschiedener komponenten
wenn jetzt einmal miteinander
funktionäre und dann hat die richtig
kocht temperatur oder so ob sie dem
fleisch fisch oder obst wie man einen
fisch ist und ich spüre sie thunfisch in
gefahr und den fcz billiton werde mit
dem fisch mit mit roter das tut schon
richtige 81 14 stunden tage sind die
regel
oft sind es mehr und bis er endlich
feierabend macht schaut er auf jedes
detail
hiernach
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
seit drei jahren lebt stefan trap nicht
mehr allein in bangkok mit seiner
freundin anna karla bewohnt er ein
apartment im stadtzentrum
anna ist journalistin und stammt aus
manila die verkörpert alles was
schweizerisch ist er ist organisiert
diszipliniert sehr fleißig das sind die
positiven seiten unter negativen es sind
kulturelle unterschiede als asiatin bin
ich nicht zu sehr besessen von
pünktlichkeit wie er das ist das noch
den manchmal wahnsinnig aber insgesamt
haben wir sehr gut zusammen
[Musik]
der chefkoch nimmt regelmäßig an
triathlons teil
wann immer möglich trainiert er und fast
jeden tag fährt der früh morgens mit dem
fahrrad zur arbeit
[Musik]
wer abschließen
das kennen das höchstens das ist mäßig
das münchen/rom vier fünf mal die woche
kommen zur alltagshektik der königliche
hunger dazu seiner majestät steht der
sinn heute nach einem stück land in
kürze werden die diener des königs die
mahlzeiten diskret abholen um das
fleisch kümmert sich der chef persönlich
dasselbe machen wenn es falsch läuft
bevor trap vor zwei jahren als chefkoch
anfangen durfte musste auch der
thailändische könig seinen segen dazu
geben
richtig so
vielmehr gehen wir mal entwickler zeigen
denn zehn meter
sind das war egal wo man beachten muss
das wie es uns geht
rotter und wenn in den pfannen danach in
hannover auf der das schön
der verschluss break wird genauso
[Musik]
so wie weg den die menschen dieser
mitarbeiter ist seit 1970 im haus
folgerichtig heißt der pilz macht viel
wurde könig ist dass wir zum beispiel
wenn dieses match ist die wm abstellen
zunächst der de mail macht das schon mit
mehr zimmer erklärte minister hätte aber
schlussendlich machen er sehr stolz ein
künstler unter ruhige natur
[Musik]
[Applaus]
endlich daheim dürfen
inzwischen ist das land schon fast parat
so wäre
[Musik]
genau richtig
genauso wie könig gerd medium zum medium
mehr darlehen sind gelder zu klassik
genau perfekt
das gold zum könig die nächste
herausforderung wartet bereits acht
manager der wichtigsten hotels der stadt
werden heute bei ihm essen zum leichten
mal gehört auch fisch doch ausgerechnet
heute passiert ist
haskins einer seiner kirche hat den
fisch zu früh gewendet
das gibt ich kann ihn nicht so wäre
ich kann nichts gewesen
da muss ich noch mal kummer vor solange
es für märkte das ok meine jackpot und
und vielseitig ist das okay
bereits wird die suppe serviert
eigentlich ist fisch
sanya golden future tec der fisch ist
fisch coming
trap braucht unbedingt mein fisch aus
dem kühlraum
[Musik]
alleinig der fischenicher fisch der
schweizer ist extrem angespannt
ich versuche es mit einem kleinen scherz
im allerletzten moment kommt mit dem
fisch die erlösung und mit der erlösung
steigt auf gleich wieder der anspruch
[Musik]
der stick schnitte und clean peter plate
doch dann hat es stefan tripp einmal
mehr geschafft
es sind diese tage die stefan trap an
seinem beruf liebt es sind die
herausforderungen die er braucht und
immer wieder sucht denn diese haben ihn
in seiner laufbahn immer weitergebracht
aber auch weiter weg von seiner familie
und von der schweiz
es gibt situationen frauen selber schon
wer nach den aktionären meisters der
werde gerne daheim mit der familie oder
wenn man geburtstag als geburtstag in
der familie werde ich sogar aber so
setzen
am abend trifft sich stefan tripp mit
seiner freundin anna in der stadt
ausnahmsweise ist er mal früher dran die
beiden wollen auswärts essen gehen
[Musik]
mit nur 900 0 1 und oder nudeln wenn es
ums essen geht war es stefan trapped
genau was er will
das hat ihn schließlich zum koch des
königs gemacht
am ziel seiner träume ist er damit aber
noch nicht
denn die größte herausforderung ist eine
private und die steht ihm noch bevor
richtigen weg
wetten dass schon mal was
sie hat gar nicht verstanden dass sich
viele besucher
[Musik]